et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les jbe qui sont en train de vieillir
pompe pour se rajeunir les shadoks de la
lune avant de partir dans l'espace
suivent une formation technique accéléré
je calcule leur avaient toujours donné
pas mal de fil à retordre étant donné
qu'il ya des quatre mou et qu'il ne
pouvait pas compter plus loin que 4 vous
souvenez mais le professeur chat de
cours avait réformé tout ça écoutons ans
quand il n'ya pas de chat d'oc ont
maudit gars et on écrit quand il ya un
shadok de plus on dit but et on écrit
quand il y en a encore un chat d'oc ont
disons et on écrit
et quand il ya encore un autre on dit me
et on écrit tout le monde a produit 7
confort et trouvé ça génial c'est le vin
que j'utilisais qu'on ne l'ait pas eu
d'insultés à des enfants des bêtises
pareilles et costa do qu il fallait le
condamner il fut très applaudi les
mathématiques ça les intéressait bien
sûr les brûler le professeur c'était
intéressant aussi pour dire qu'il eut
décidé à l'unanimité qu'on le laissait
parler des coûts le brûler après à la
règle et a répété avec moi maison bugat
gars buso me crie après qu'elle ait le
plombier si je mets un shadok en plus
évidemment je n'ai plus assez de mots
pour les côtés alors c'est très sain on
les jette dans une poubelle et je dis
que j'ai bu poubelles et pour ne pas
confondre avec le but du début je dis
qu'il n'ya pas de chat d'oc à côté de la
poubelle et j'écris du gars on continue
nos poubelles et pas de chat d'oc à côté
de poubelles
si je mets un shadok en plus il me faut
une autre poubelle
mais comme je n'ai plus de mots pour
compter des poubelles je m'en débarrasse
en les jetant dans une grande poubelle
j'écris but grande poubelle avec pas de
petites poubelles n'est pas de shadow
qu'à côté bulgare gars et on continue
quand on arrive là et qu'on a trop de
grandes poubelles pour pouvoir les
compter et bien on les met dans une
super poubelle on écrit
but gag haga et on continue mais le
donne à fond bien crier que tout ça
c'était pas clair qu'on avait écrit un
autre là sur la pancarte et que si
demain les écolières n'est pas trouvée
confiait ce cadeau que ça faisait
et bien on le brûle ré jusqu'au bout le
professeur tout cela semblait assez mal
parti pour lui si d'ici notre prochaine
émission certains d'entre vous trouvent
comment ce nombre château que j'écris en
français il serait bien aimable de nous
communiquer
[Musique]